wir kommen an der militärakademie wiener
neustadt mein name ist oberst markus
reissner ich bin der leiter der
forschungs und entwicklungsabteilung der
theresianischen militärakademie und
heute wollen wir uns in einem neuen
video damit befassen welche fähigkeiten
und taktiken im hintergrund eine ganz
wesentliche rolle in diesem konflikt
spielen fähigkeiten und taktiken die uns
auf den ersten blick gar nicht auffallen
die aber ganz wesentlich zum erfolg von
ukrainischer seite bis jetzt beigetragen
haben dazu müssen wir ganz kurz den
konflikt seit dem 24 februar betrachten
dann beginnen in den ersten zwei wochen
war es so dass die russische seite
relativ rasch geländegewinne durchführen
konnte es gab einen angriff von vier
freunden im norden im nordosten osten
und im süden und der vormals schlager
von geprägt dass die russischen opera
strache angefallen sind
in der dritten woche begannen dann die
ersten herausforderungen die sich weiter
fortgesetzt haben das waren die angriffe
auf die logistik kongress waren die
angriffe der ukrainischen spezialkräfte
ganz gezielt auf gefecht stände aber vor
allem auch der einsatz der artillerie
der dazu beigetragen hat dass am ende
der sechsten woche die russische seite
entschieden hat ein schwergewicht im
donbass zu bilden die truppen im norden
abzuziehen sich hier neu zu
konzentrieren
und wenn man die letzten wochen
betrachten so sieht man auch dass die
kämpfe sich vor allem im kompass
abspielen die ukrainische seite versucht
was sie dem entgegen zu wirken durch
angriffe an den anderen freundinnen und
die russen versuchen hier entsprechend
entgegenzuhalten
jetzt kann man sich die frage stellen in
diesen letzten knapp zwölf wochen was
hat gut funktioniert und warum hat so
gut funktioniert wie wissen drei
wesentliche dinge waren der fall das
erste war die taktik der ukraine der
einsatz gegen die logistik linien gegen
die logistik konto ist der einsatz der
gezielten artillerie schläge aber auch
der einsatz der spezialkräfte und
natürlich die hohe moral der ukrainische
soldaten das zweite wesentliche sind
natürlich die massiven waffenlieferungen
vor allem jene waffensysteme die haben
beginn geholfen haben diesen
abnutzungseffekt auf die russische seite
durchzuführen und das mit elements das
auch ganz wesentlich ist natürlich
übermittlung von aufklärungsdaten der
usa und nato die ukrainische seite
bewegt hat diese einsätze durchzuführen
schauen wir uns nun im speziellen die
artillerie an denn der einsatz der
ukrainischen artillerie- ist sehr
bemerkenswert und scheint für uns sehr
wichtig wenn man diesen konflikt
betrachten hier wird kurz skizziert den
traditionellen sehr vereinfacht
dargestellt ein einsatz von artillerie
wir haben einen so genannten forward
observer der abgesessen oder mit einer
drohne ein ziel aufklären kann diese
daten übermittelt er dann über eine
struktur also kommando und kontroll
einführungs element dass diese frau
anforderung dann allein blick system in
diesem fall eine pm 27 batterie
weitergibt diese bm 27 batterie befindet
sich in einen definierten stellungs
rahmen einer politischen jahre alt die
kommunikation funktioniert durch ein
battle management system oder
einführungs informationssystem
wenn ein ziel erkannt wird dann wird das
ziel aufgeklärt und diese ziel daten
weitergegeben und in letzter konsequenz
kommt es zum einsatz von einem wirt
mittel auf das ziel selbst im laufe der
letzten jahrzehnte konnte diese zeit die
man dazu gebracht hat immer wieder
optimiert werden von wenigen minuten die
man dazu gebracht hat bzw wurde sie auch
immer wieder in die länge gezogen
aufgrund der vorgaben zum beispiel das
humanitären völkerrechts also die frage
besteht die gefahr eines
kollateralschaden dass das so zu prüfen
war auch jetzt diese forderung wirklich
legitim war
der punkt war dass bei einem derartigen
traditionell einsatz immer das problem
auch bestand dass wenn der gegner
bewirkt worden ist durch ein wirksysteme
ja natürlich versucht hat dem
entgegenzuwirken indem er durch eigene
filialsysteme entgegen vorher
durchgeführt hat das heißt in diesem
fall hatte sie die russische seite mit
einer batterie bm 21 die ukrainische
seite bewirkt und hier schwere ausfälle
verursacht zusätzlich kommt hinzu dass
die kommunikation immer wieder der
herausforderung durch störer unterliegt
das heißt die kommunikation sei
eingeschränkt durchgeführt wird
beziehungsweise herausforderungen gibt
es die man nicht lösen kann und damit
auch die zeit für die forderung sich in
die länge zieht
wenn wir uns nun die erfahrungen der
ukrainische seite anschauen aus dem
konflikt mit beginnen 2014 und den
letzten jahren so erkennt man anhand
dieses beispiels dass die masse der
ausfälle der ukrainische seite was also
quasi die kampffahrzeuge betroffen hat
vor allem durch gegnerische nationale
system erfolgt ist sie sehen dass hier
in diesem balkon sie sehen das
gepanzerte fahrzeuge zu 45 prozent
ausgefallen sind aufgrund von artillerie
treffern artillerie systeme sogar
aufgrund von 65 prozent ein klarer
indikator für erfolgreiches gegen vor
der russischen seite oder auch
allgemeine fahrzeuge zu 57 prozent das
heißt die ukrainische seite musste etwas
ändern und was ihr bei einem neuen
konflikt hier erfolgreicher zu sein was
war das
sie haben die art und weise des ateliers
geändert das system blieb grundsätzlich
gleich es gibt nach wie vor dem
beobachter eher ein ziel erkennen kann
es ist einfach so dass quasi der
vorstellungs rauen der artillerie in
einer viel aufgelockert werden vorhaben
passiert im sogenannten stellungs raum
verfahren das heißt die geschütze oder
wird mittel sehen sie auf einen größeren
raum verteilt die kommunikation erfolgt
durch zwei aller dinge einerseits durch
eine sehr gezielt von der ukrainischen
seite entwickelte software namens gs
alter aber auch in kommunikation mit
einem verbindungsmittel dass wir so
nicht am radar haben aber eine sehr
wichtige rolle spielt nämlich mit dem
systems darlehen von alaska wie läuft
jetzt ein derartiger einsatz ab auch
hier ist es so dass wenn ein ziel
erkannt wird diese daten also die
koordinaten aufgenommen werden von dem
beobachter und weitergegeben werden
jesus aber wichtig zu verstehen dass die
weitergabe der daten so erfolgt dass
viele in sehr kurzer zeit die
möglichkeit haben ihre fähigkeiten zur
anwendung zu bringen das heißt ihre
waffen systeme einzusetzen das heißt
durch diese app im wesentlichen ist es
möglich diese koordination durchzuführen
oder nach vorn dass die zeit für die
verantwortung wesentlich verringert wird
auf wenige minuten und dann alle jene
systeme die in der nähe sind oder die
reichweite die effektive haben sofort
wirksam werden können zusätzlich noch in
kombination mit dem umstand dass die
munition die dafür eingesetzt wird wie
hier in diesem fall eine endfassung
gesteuerten munition ist der große
vorteil ist wenn jetzt die russische
seite versucht mit gegenfeuer zu
antworten dann hat sie das problem dass
aufgrund des dezentralen einsatzes der
batterie oder weg mitteln sie vor der
herausforderung steht ihr maximales
feuer auf sehr wenige möglichkeiten
konzentrieren zu müssen das heißt sie
kann die batterie als gesamtes nicht
vernichten das problem besteht auch dass
du die satellitenkommunikation der
einsatz von störern sehr schwierig wird
die kurse normalerweise den funkverkehr
stören sondern da muss ich angriffen
muss also auf diese
satellitenkommunikation abzielen sehen
wir uns nun die kernelemente des
einsatzes zu klinischen atelier noch
einmal im detail land dazu habe ich im
öffentlichen netz einige recherchen
durchgeführt und die kernaussagen möchte
ich ihnen nun zeigen beginnen wir mit
dieser apps von ukrainischen software
ingenieuren entwickelt in sehr kurzer
zeit und sehr effektiv der große vorteil
ist die schnelle unterstützung eine sehr
einfache benutzeroberfläche wie in
diesen bildern erkennbar wo die
koordinaten eingegeben werden und rasch
dehnfähigkeit pflegern also den
aktuellen systemen zur verfügung
gestellt werden das zweite wesentliche
ist starling das system von e on mars
ihr wissen wir dass die
benutzeroberfläche ebenfalls einfach ist
das heißt wir haben also eine gewisse
bandbreite wir haben die möglichkeit der
kommunikation über viele satelliten über
1760 anbieten die sich hier bereits in
der erdumlaufbahn finden und wir haben
auch bandbreiten die große datenmengen
zu übertragen es zu lassen wir wissen
auch dass anbeginn die russische seite
sehr wohl versucht hat dies zu stören
dabei gab es sogar einen sei defekt in
den europäischen ländern wo zum beispiel
sehr viele windkraftanlagen betroffen
waren immer noch gibt hier in diesem
tweet bekannt das ist nicht gelungen ist
der russischen seite das system zu
stören und diese störversuche dauert
noch an gesehen dass hier in einem
weiteren kurzen twitter eintrag von in
omas vor wenigen tagen wo er darauf
hinweist dass die russische seite nach
wie vor versucht die kommunikation zu
stören warum ist das wichtig weil
natürlich diese kommunikation ganz
wesentlich dazu beitragen dass die
ukrainische seite vor allem ihr atelier
systeme einsetzen kann
dieses dezentrale internet spielt als
eine wesentliche rolle was im konflikt
das dritte wichtige element ist
natürlich bereits erwähnt die munition
hier ist ganz interessant dass die
ukrainische seite ein russisches system
nachgebaut hat die russische seite hat
so genannte endphasen gesteuerte
artilleriegranaten vom typ krasnow polen
die ukrainische seite hat diese
nachgebaut und hat ihr eigenes system
entwickelt namens quick nick das ist
auch der hintergrund warum wir oft in
den videos sehr gezielte anschläge also
der erste treffer ist oft bereits der
der das fahrzeug zum beispiel zerstört
das precise tage ding die zentrale
kommunikation aber auch der umstand hier
rasch wirksam werden zu können ist ganz
wesentlich für die einsatzführung der
ukrainischen artillerie-
sehen wir uns nun ein paar ausgewählte
beispiele ein beispiel von beginn des
konflikts das war dieser rasche vorstoß
aus dem raum sumi der russischen kräfte
entlang einer zentral geführten linien
richtung kiew hier gibt es ein sehr
bekanntes video wo man erkennen kann
dass der russische chor sehr gezielt
durch artillerie angegriffen wird und
viele fahrzeuge zerstört werden ein
gutes beispiel für den sehr frühen
einsatz von gsa
ein zweites beispiel ist gegen feuer
auch hier ein beispiel aus dem süden des
landes es gibt immer wieder artillerie
duelle zwischen nikolai fund person von
beiden seiten hier gibt es auch ein
video das sehr interessant ist es zeigt
nämlich eine gezogene russische
artillerie batterie nachdem gegen feuer
durch die ukrainische seite mit sehr
verheerender wirkung auch hier kann man
gut erkennen dass sie das atelier vater
russen sofort von ukrainischer seite
lokalisiert worden ist und es eine
effektive es gegenfeuer gegeben hat
der dritte nicht zu unterschätzende fall
ist auch hier ein beispiel um zu zeigen
dass es gerade auch der angriff der
rumänischen artillerie auf die
führungskommunikation und
führungsstruktur ganz wesentlich war wir
wissen dass bis heute ca 13 russische
generäle und man ihm dann über 20
oberste gefallen sind warum ist das der
fall weil die ukrainische seite ist er
gezielt versucht die gefecht ständig
anzugreifen hier ein beispiel aus dem
raum ist um ist was jener raum wo die
russische seite versucht bei der
schlacht im drum bass die sogenannte
nördliche zangenbewegung zu entwickeln
hier gab es am 30 april einen angriff
aufzubauen wo man annimmt dass ein
russischer general nämlich jeder halter
verantwortlich ist für die elektronische
kampfführung getötet worden ist durch
den gezielten einsatz der ukrainische
artillerie
schlüsselmomente in der schlacht sind
natürlich wesentliche
treiber des konflikts auch hier ist ein
beispiel dass er in den letzten tagen
sehr intensiv kommuniziert worden ist
wieder heran zu ziehen um zu zeigen dass
der gezielte ukraine der artillerie sehr
effektiv sein kann die situation war die
dass in der nähe von biel orf in der
nähe vom giro thron jetzt die russische
seite versucht hat durch mehrere
brückenschläge die ukrainische seite in
der tiefe zu umfassen das hat dann
beginnt auch funktioniert man ist also
über den sie was getan jetzt diesen
markanten fluss hinüber gekommen und hat
kräftig weil sie bereitgestellt am
ostufer diese kräfte wurden aber
zurückgedrängt daraufhin at russische
seite versucht an anderer stelle neuen
brückenschlag durchzuführen auch dies
aber nicht erfolgreich woraufhin die
russische seite zum dritten mal versucht
er eine brücke zu legen und hier massiv
kräfte hinüber zu führen die ukrainische
seite hat diese zeit aber genutzt und
hat bis zum zehnten mal nicht nur eigene
kräfte zusammengeführt sondern auch
artillerie systeme bereitgestellt und
als die russen versucht haben massiv
über diese zwei punkte um brücken dem
fluss zu wirklich an kam es zu einem
vernichtenden abwehr feuer und man nimmt
an dass vermutlich zwei bataillons
taktische guten hier zerschlagen wenn
nicht gar vernichtet worden sind auch
hier wird ein beispiel der guten
koordination der ukrainischen artillerie
zur erreichung eines gezielten abbau
erfolge
am ende des videos möchte ich ihnen
dieses bild zeigen es zeigt eine
russische minister batterie also schwere
artilleriegeschütze vom kaliber 152 mm
die sich hier in einem windschutzgürtel
unter gezogen haben das ist ein klarer
indikator dafür dass man versucht
möglichst unerkannt ins feuer weiter
einen verein zu bringen wir haben aber
auch hier noch immer diesen
traditionellen vorstellungs raum wo die
geschütze relativ eng nebeneinander
stehen
interessant ist dass die ukrainische
seite eine mix zwischen alter taktik und
neuer taktik angewandt hat das heißt wir
haben also innovative taktiken und
gefechts techniken und wir haben
herkömmliche taktiken und beides in
kombination bin diesem zitat auch
dargestellt hat offensichtlich dazu
geführt dass die ukrainische seite in
den letzten 12 wochen das konflikt vor
allem was den einsatz der artillerie
betroffen hat sie erfolgreich diese
maßnahmen durchgeführt hat damit bin ich
am ende und ist herzlichen dank fürs
zuhören